[Music]
on this Friday night Ontario School
chaos
thousands of Education workers walk off
the job we've had enough of Doug Ford in
the Ontario PCS taking advantage of the
most vulnerable segments of society as
the province moves to have the strike
declared illegal
buckle up for political pandemonium why
the U.S midterms could dull Canada's
Auto shine get red as a former U.S
president hints at a comeback
one of the world's toughest Animals in
Danger they're super tough that can
survive Winters they can survive
Avalanches they live in places where
nobody else lives so why are Canada's
Wolverines struggling to survive
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us an anxiety-filled weekend lies ahead
for tens of thousands of families in
Ontario after education support workers
walked off the job their Defiance has
been deemed illegal by the Ford
government and it comes after a
months-long bitter standoff with the
province but today their strike action
left parents in Canada's biggest school
board scrambling
we don't really know what we're going to
do it will become very challenging yes
definitely
um so holiday time will definitely have
to be used up sick days will have to be
used up to accommodate that child care
with no end in sight to the conflict
makeshift child care options popped up
across the region but those may not be
viable in the coming days as thousands
of striking workers say they won't Buck
down
we're going to have more on the future
of the strike in just a moment but first
Eric Sorensen begins our coverage with
how we got here
across Ontario protests large and small
by 55 000 education workers defying the
Ontario government's attempt to force
them to go to work the dispute mainly
over wages has forced many schools to
close it's gone far enough where we've
been underpaid and not compensated for
the work that we do the minister of
education and the majority Government
tried to bully and intimidate them
decided that they are not going to just
stand for that day the Ford government
insisted children have missed too much
in-class learning already from the
pandemic so an extraordinary measure was
necessary invoking the notwithstanding
Clause bypassing arbitration and other
legislative measures for the sake of
Ontario's 2 million students and their
parents schools must remain open the
notwithstanding Clause was inserted into
the Charter of Rights and Freedoms 40
years ago but its use was intended to be
exceedingly rare because it could
override basic rights it has turned a
provincial labor dispute into a national
Firestorm over those rights and we are
absolutely looking at all different
options the federal government could
apply its own powers to override
Ontario's law but the Prime Minister
says Canadians should speak up it should
be Canadians saying hold on a minute
you're suspending my right
the collective bargaining you're
suspending fundamental rights and
freedoms that are afforded to us in the
charter it's not the first time the Ford
government has turned to the
notwithstanding Clause but the pushback
this time was quick if the government is
left to get away with it
every person in Canada regardless of
their political opinion could be left
with almost no Charter protections at
all months ago Doug Ford won a massive
majority and hinted that he has public
opinion on his side you know we live in
a democracy people spoke June 2nd very
loud but that popularity will be tested
as will support for striking workers the
longer the children now at home remain
out of school the idea that this is now
going to go on for a longer period of
time is very worrisome especially
um from the academic and social
emotional aspects of kids development
the Ford government wanted a swift
simple solution that would ensure
schools stayed open but it has instead
is a public Tempest and many of those
schools are now closed anyway Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
let's go now to Queen's Park bureau
chief Colin Demello calling many parents
will be on the edge of their seats this
weekend so what does next week look like
at this point
well at this point we don't know there
are so many moving Parts but school
boards have been told to prepare for the
worse and that means sending kids back
to online learning after a two-year
pandemic that had a lot of kids in
Ontario spending weeks behind a laptop
learning from far away from school we
know that the union says that they want
to have a protracted strike and the only
thing that will end the strike is one of
a few options either the Ford government
comes back with a new contract offer and
rescinds its prior legislation Bill 28
or if the workers themselves say they've
had enough and they want to return to
work but as of right now we've got no
way of knowing exactly what this Union
plans to do next because even they won't
reveal their options to us pharah so so
what could happen though I mean what
could trigger an end to this strike
well right now the Ontario government is
in front of the Ontario Labor Relations
Board they're trying to make the
argument that this strike is illegal a
bill 28 which was passed into law
yesterday made this strike by uh the
Canadian Union of public employees
workers illegal and so if that happens
if they get that declaration they might
be able to start handing out fines half
a million dollars to the union itself
and potentially up to four thousand
dollars per individual employee if those
fines start being handed out that the
government is hoping those employees
might cave although today unifor the
biggest Union in this country has
announced they've handed over about a
hundred thousand dollars to this Union
to their strike fund so if they've got
the finances to back them they may not
back down meaning this continues to be a
stalemate and it could be that way for a
few days or weeks to come
and students and parents could go back
to online learning okay thank you so
much Colin Colin Demello in Toronto for
us tonight
paying off student loans will be less of
a headache for post-secondary Canadian
students one of the key measures that
was unveiled in the government's fall
economic update is federal student loan
interest will be permanently eliminated
the average Canadian graduates with more
than thirteen thousand dollars in
federal debt alone the change is meant
to help ease pressure but as Abigail
Beeman explains there's concern
Canadians are not getting the money when
they need it money is tight for second
year student Andy Suarez I have to
manage my rent and I have to manage my
food I can't spend too much on food I
have to more or less ration what I can
buy from Walmart and he's luckier than
some with help from family and federal
student loans I have
let's say about 20 000 right now I'm
trying to look uh to reduce that when he
graduates he'll now save on interest
for students we are permanently
eliminating interest on Canada student
loans and apprenticeship loans that's
something that we've long called for and
finally is being achieved the government
says it will cost 2.7 billion dollars
over five years and save the average
student 410 dollars a year well this is
Monumental news for students across
Canada the move lauded by the Canadian
Alliance of student associations
students once they've graduated no
they're trying to establish themselves
they're looking for jobs in their field
or jobs of their interest and this takes
time still got three years left so good
news that's pretty difficult now with
inflation and
working and studying at the same time
but others are skeptical this isn't a
free lunch it's a shell game because the
students are going to have to pay
through pay for this through higher
government debt this change in the
interest rate policy affects other
people whose incomes are high enough to
be able to afford repayment under
ottawa's separate repayment Assistance
Plan students don't have to pay back
loans at all until they make at least
forty thousand dollars a year Christine
Neal studies post-secondary policy and
calls canceling interest inefficient for
getting people money when they need it
if we reduce the available funds on the
student lineage aside chances are it's
going to come back to bite Us in terms
of less money for students up front
while many student Advocates say the
more help up front for students through
any means the better Abigail Global News
Ottawa
new data from statistics Canada shows
the economy is seeing unexpected strong
growth 108 000 jobs were added in
October that's about 10 times What was
forecast the unemployment rate held
steady at 5.2 percent as more Canadians
were looking for work employment Rose
across a broad range of sectors but it
was led by manufacturing construction
accommodation and Food Services the jobs
gains comes after four months of losses
or a little employment growth in Canada
the public inquiry into the federal
government's decision to invoke the
emergencies act in February to end weeks
of protests in Ottawa heard from several
of the so-called Freedom Convoy
organizers this week today the
commission cross-examined far-right
podcaster Jeremy McKenzie as David Akin
reports RCMP believed Mckenzie was
behind a dangerous extremist group that
helped fuel the protests
in a letter he sent to Senators last
winter Jeremy McKenzie described himself
as quote the de facto leader of the
so-called extremist organization known
as diagonalon but in that letter
Mackenzie told Senators that his group
was in fact harmless
that though is not an opinion National
Security and police agencies share about
McKenzie or Diagon the RCMP has
described diagonalon let me be specific
has described diagonalon as a
militia-like network with members that
are armed and preparing for violence on
Friday McKenzie became a reluctant
witness at the commission reviewing the
federal government's decision to invoke
the emergencies act reluctant because
Mackenzie was testifying from a jail in
Saskatoon where he awaits trial on
weapons and other charges not related to
any Convoy activities but he had been in
Ottawa during last Winter's Convoy
protests this was going to be a very
significant event it was very clear to
me this was not going to be a in and out
you know weekend protest type of thing
his presence attracted the attention of
cecis which prepared an analytical brief
expressing concern about diagonalon and
McKenzie this is a thesis a document
but it has is a box here that says in
Jeremy McKenzie's own words later the
country would learn that some of those
arrested at the Coots border crossing
and charged with conspiracy to murder
RCMP officers wore some of the symbols
Diagon has adopted Mackenzie knew and
had socialized with at least one of
those charged one reason why Mackenzie
and other diagonal community members
represented the kind of potentially
dangerous presence that could have
played a role in the Trudeau
government's decision to invoke the
emergencies act but Mackenzie testified
he represented no threat I was just
doing my best to mitigate any potential
any influence that I have to try to you
know push things in a positive direction
the commission's work continues Monday
and will turn its focus to events in
Coots Alberta and Windsor Ontario David
Aiken Global News
Ottawa will he or won't he looks like
former U.S president Donald Trump is
leaning towards a possible comeback and
now in order to make our country
successful and safe and glorious
I will very very very probably do it
again okay
Trump's advisors say a possible
announcement could be coming in the next
few weeks in order to get ahead of
potential Rivals for the party's
nomination but they say it's also
possible he could delay or change his
mind altogether
next week's midterm elections in the U.S
could drive change here in Canada coming
up the consequences to our Auto industry
plus protecting Canada's Wolverines why
the resilient animal is struggling to
survive
next week's midterm elections in the U.S
could have consequences for Canadian
companies particularly those in the Auto
industry
the sector supports nearly 500 000
workers and contributes 16 billion
dollars each year to this country's
gross domestic product most of the
vehicles made here are sold South of the
Border but there are fears that if
Republicans take control of Congress the
party will hit the brakes on Joe Biden's
incentives for electric vehicles our
Jeff sempel was recently in Detroit and
has more
well for the first time in a long time
the sun has been shining on Canada's
Auto sector and On the Border City of
Windsor Ontario but with the upcoming
U.S midterms there could be clouds on
the horizon
Canada's Automotive capital is in high
gear this is the Windsor Detroit tunnel
driven by Investments like the city's
new Innovation Hub which allows car
companies to test drive products and
Technologies in virtual reality
well just down the road this
construction site is the future home of
Canada's first lithium-ion electric
vehicle battery plant the result of a
five billion dollar investment announced
last spring creating thousands of jobs
incredible Resurgence in the Auto
industry the head of the Border City's
Economic Development Group says after
years of bad news the industry is making
a comeback around 85 percent of Canadian
Cars and auto parts are exported to the
United States where Canada's car makers
recently won another Victory the Biden
administration's inflation reduction act
replaced its buy America provision with
a tax credit for green Vehicles produced
in North America it encourages adoption
which supports the manufacturing and its
benefits the North American Partners so
it's it's it's phenomenal but there is
concern that a republican-controlled
congress might pull a U-turn the
Liberals in the Biden Administration are
clueless and out of touch Republican
candidates are campaigning against the 7
500 tax credit with ads condemning
electric vehicles as expensive and
Un-American every Republican voted
against the Omnibus Bill and if they
take control of Congress they could
interfere with its implementation it's
possible for opposition congresses to
undermine the intent of those policies
through budgets through other procedures
and mechanisms U.S automakers are also
pushing back warning few Vehicles would
even qualify for the tax credit because
North America doesn't currently produce
enough battery components so there are a
lot of things that need to be worked out
still we first see some tinkering this
Michigan Auto industry rep expects there
will be changes to the electric vehicle
incentive program but one way or another
the industry is going green
the political debate around electric
vehicles does that worry you does that
worry the industry no because the market
forces are going to drive it ultimately
the market needs to be supplied so the
companies press on Biden's Bill also
provides incentives for manufacturers to
build their EV batteries in the U.S that
could make it harder for Canada to
compete the manufacturers are going to
go where it makes the most business
sense to go and right now the U.S is
really putting the full court press on
that entire carbon transition ecosystem
so of course we're curious to see how
that pans out and how that gets written
up a lot is riding on how Washington
moves forward with its EV agenda
regardless of who wins on November the
8th Canada's Auto sector is confident
they're on the road to revitalization
Jeff sempel in Detroit and we're going
to have full coverage of the midterm
elections next week from Washington D.C
As Americans head to the polls
Twitter employees around the world are
finding out today if they still have a
job
it comes after speculation and
uncertainty about the future of the
company under its new owner Elon Musk
internal plans leaked earlier this week
show musk wants to cut 3 700 staff
members or about half of Twitter staff
at least two of those let go today were
in senior positions in the company's
Canadian office mosque who is the
world's richest man wants to slash costs
and impose a demanding new work ethic at
least one photo posted to social media
this week showed an employee sleeping at
the office in order to meet deadlines
[Music]
ahead a royal affair on climate change
the king hosts world leaders ahead of a
major Summit
[Music]
former Pakistani prime minister Imran
Khan has spoken out publicly for the
first time since his assassination
attempt yesterday he is accusing his
successors of being involved in a plot
to kill him
speaking from a wheelchair at the
hospital where he's recovering Khan
named the current Pakistani prime
minister the interior Minister and a
senior Army Commander as accomplices in
the plot he provided no evidence to back
up the claims the assassination attempt
killed one man and wounded at least 10
others Khan's accusations came as
hundreds of his supporters clashed with
police in cities right across the
country
King Charles held a meeting today with
global leaders ahead of the U.N climate
Summit cop 27.
oh this is extraordinary
more than 200 people attended the
reception including Britain's new prime
minister Rishi sunak the king is well
known for being outspoken on
environmental issues but he will not be
attending cop 27. Charles has indicated
he's going to step back publicly from
championing such causes since becoming
Monarch the United Nations conference
begins this weekend in Egypt
they are mysterious animals but the
Wolverine population in western Canada
is dwindling I'm Heather urich's West in
Banff National Park I'll have that story
coming up
despite having a tough reputation new
research shows that the population of
one of the world's most elusive animals
The Wolverine is rapidly declining in
Canada as Heather urac's West explains
the species appears to be struggling due
to human impacts including climate
change
mysterious beautiful and Incredibly
Fierce Wolverines thrive in some of the
harshest areas of Canada's Rockies
places where other animals do not
they're just so incredible right they're
super tough they can survive Winters
they can survive Avalanches they live in
places where nobody else lives and yet
according to new research these animals
are in trouble so when I walk in they
leave hair after collecting DNA from
hair samples and videos of the animals
for over a decade in Western Canada's
Banff Yoho and Kootenai national parks a
team of researchers have made a sobering
discovery
it was a bit of a wake-up call for us
researchers we didn't expect what we
found even within the relative safety of
the national parks The Wolverine
population is dwindling down almost 40
percent since 2011 and a big reason for
that is climate change we know what
Wolverines need to thrive they need very
large connected habitat that's also that
doesn't have a lot of disturbance from
people
they also need to know they do they are
a cold adapted species there's no
adapted species the good news is this
part of the rocky mountain range in BC
and Alberta is warming at a slower rate
than other areas but even here the
population has declined in response to
the numbers Parks Canada has made
changes to a small area of the Kootenai
National Park to limit human activity
around Wolverine habitats that's just
means that that's a place where we're
going to reduce our Trail maintenance
try and reduce human presence and allow
Wolverine to to use a place like that
without very much human presence in 2020
just after researchers finished
collecting their data the BC government
introduced a limit of one Wolverine per
Trapper per year but now that this study
has revealed how sensitive the
population is researchers hope more
restrictions will follow it looks like a
nice Wolverine track we're tracking
these elusive creatures may become even
more difficult with fewer and fewer left
in the Parks to find Heather urich's
West Global News Lake Louise Alberta
they're mesmerizing that's global
national for this Friday night I'm Farah
Nasser and tonight's your Canada is
Banff Alberta as seen from the top of
sulfur Mountain
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
foreign